but this lava is the first summit during
which we discussed the common future of
27 states without the UK we will not
continue business as usual to move the
EU forward we have discussed the
Bratislava roadmap which sets out the
objectives for our work ahead of the raw
meeting in march next year when we want
to conclude this process we are
determined to continue our cooperation
is turkey and Western Balkans but also
to establish my gracious compacts with
African countries to do everything
necessary to support member states in
ensuring internal security and fighting
terrorism to strengthen your cooperation
on external security and defense I hope
that the Bratislava summit will lead to
the renewing of trust and confidence in
the european union today I can say the
Delta I was very pleased that today we
were able to agree on the Bratislava
declaration today and we have sketched
out a Bratislava roadmap which we could
describe as a shared political intention
of the heads of state and government of
the EU for the coming months um so in
that sense I think we can say that the
Bratislava summit has been a success I
must tell you how satisfied I am that
the European Council and I think all
leaders join me in expressing the
satisfaction I'm very satisfied that my
speech on the State of the Union before
the European Parliament a few days ago
has been welcomed I noted with great
satisfaction that one of the scent the
centerpieces of my speech was welcomed
and that was an unanimous agreement on
the Digital Agenda which is essential
for the modernization of Europe it's
essential for our
nomming growth and it's essential if
we're to create new jobs we now have a
working agenda which in the spirit of
Bratislava will enable us to make
progress over the coming months